يوصل مجلس محافظه لوكاله الدوليه لتقريه
مناقشاته في فيينا بشان ملف ايران النووي
وتحقيقات الوكاله بشان مواقع ايرانيه
وافادت مصادر الدبلوماسيه للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والثلاثي الاوروبي
فرنسا وبريطانيا والمانيا قدمت مشروع قرار
لتصويت عليه يودين ما تصفه بعدم تعاون
طهران مع الوكاله الدوليه وفي هذا السياق
صدر بيان اوروبي وثلاثي ضمه كلا من
بريطانيا وفرنسا والمانيا اعتبر ان تصعيد
ايران النووي غير مسبوقه ويشكل تهديدا
للامن الدولي والاقليمي وحسن بيان ايران
على الوقت الفوري لما وصفه بتصعيد النووي
واعتماد الشفافيه الكامله مع الوكاله
الدوليه
لقد دانت الخارجيه الايرانيه تقديم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وفرنسا
وبريطانيا والمانيا مشروعه قرار ضد ايران
في اجتماع مجلس حكام الوكاله الدوليه
وقال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه ناصر كنعاني
قال ان اجراء واشنطن والثلاثيه الاوروبي
امر غير مقبوله وسيؤثر بشكل سلبي على مسار
المفاوضات بين ايران والوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه واعتبر كنعاني ان واشنطن
والثلاثيه الاوروبيه لممارسه ضغط سياسيا
على ايران من خلال محاوله تمرير قرار في
مجلس حكام وكاله
ومعنى من مراسل الجزيره نور الدين الدغير
و ينضم الينا كذلك من داخل مقر الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه في فيينا مراسل
الجزيره حافظ مريربح وابدا معك نور الدين
طهران الى اي مدى يعتقد ان مشروع القرار
هذا قد يؤثر على العلاقه بين ايران
والوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه وعلى مسار
المفاوضات كذلك
بالنسبه لايران في ظل الحديث الايرانيه
على انها في التواصل دائم مع الوكاله
الدوليه الطاقه الذريه كان هناك وفد
ايراني وصل الاسبوع الماضي الى فيينا واجر
محادثات مع الوكاله مع المدير العام
للوكاله وتم الاتفاق عمليا على ان يكون
هناك وفد اخر من الوكاله يصل خلال هذه
الفتره الى طهران من اجل بحث هذه المسائل
العالقه لذلك طهران تنظر على ان ما يتم
تحريكه من ملف نووي ايراني داخل الوكاله
الدول التقى الذريه يريد بشكل او باخر
اقصاء هذا الجانب من المفاوضات ما بين
ايران والوكاله الدول
رئيس منظمات الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه احمد
محمد سلامه كان واضحا امسح حينما تحدث الي
يقول بانه لا معنى وكاله اذا صدر هذا
القرار وبالتالي اصدار هذا القرار بشكل
بيقول هي الطاقه الذريه هنا في ايران
وخاصه في البحث عن الاجوبه بمساله المناطق
التي تقول الوكاله الدوليه التقدريه بانها
عثرت على اثار الوقود على اثار لليورانيوم
في تلك المناطق وهنا نقطه اساسيه ربما قد
تدفع هذه الخطوه ايران الى تصعيد النووي
جزء ربما سواء بزياده التخصيب سواء بزياده
المركزي او باعلان اجهزه مركزي وهو ربما
قد يصعب بشكل او باخر حتى مساله الحديث عن
العوده الى الاتفاق النبوي لكن ما قد يزعج
كثيرا بشكل عملي هو ان يتحول هذا القرار
الى مفعول قانوني ربما ينقل الملف الى
الوكاله ويبدو ان هذا الامر غير مطروح
حاليا همم ابقى معنا نور الدين حافظ
الايرانيه في اي اجواء تسير هذه المناقشات
هل رشحت اي معلومات بهذا الخصوص
نعم وسيله في الحقيقه المباحثات وجلسه
متواصله جلسه مجلس محافظه الوكاله الدوليه
للتقدريه من الواضح بحسب ما اعلنه ااا
مندوب روسيا هنا في فيينا ميخائيل نوف انه
ليس ثمه اتفاق بين مختلف الدول المشاركه
حول مشروع القرار هذا وقال ان المرور الى
تصويت امر حتمي وهذا كان امرا منتظرا في
الحقيقه ان الجميع غير موافق على مشروع
القرار هذا تماما كما كان عليه الحال خلال
شهر يونيو الماضي عندما رفضت كل من الصين
وروسيا قرارا ممثلا ان ذاك اغضب ايران
وجعلها تنزع الكاميرات واليه المراقبه من
المنشات النوويه اليوم الامر لا يختلف
كثيرا في الحقيقه الثلاثي الاوروبي
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه يحذرون مما
يعتبرونه تصعيدا ايرانيا خطيرا في الملف
النووي وتراجعا كبيرا عن تعاهدته طهران
نوويه هم يطالبون من خلال هذا القرار ومن
خلال ما رشح من داخل قاعه الجلسات المغلقه
وايضا ما قاله الامريكيون والبريطانيون
خصوصا هو جعل طهران وارجاعها الى الالتزام
بالحد الادنى من تعهداتها التي جاءت سواء
في الاتفاق النووي لعام 2015 او في
اتفاقيه الدوليه اخرى هم يعتبرون ان ما
تقوم به ايران حاليا خطير ويدعونها الى
التعاون مع الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه الذريه
وايضا الرد على التساؤلات التي توصف هنا
في فيينا بالمشروعه للوكاله حول وجود
يورانيوم في مواقع غير مصرح بها وغير ذلك
المدير العام للوكاله روسي قال ان لديه
مفتوحه لايران وهو يسعى جاهدا لقاء الحوار
والتعاون مع ايران قائما قال ان القرار
همم تم التصويت عليه هو وسيله من الوسائل
للضغط على ايران على حد تعبيره روسي من
اجل التعاون مع الوكاله وان تبقى همم
البرنامج النووي وصفها جروسي بالطموح
لايران تحت انظري الوكاله نعم وسيم
شكرا جزيلا لك ما اشكر كذلك مراسلنا من
طهران نوردين